you know we do that shirt the shirts
yeah we'd sell merch and I'm doing the
the meet and greet and one of the guys
come up to me and Canadians are they're
so nice they come up to me I'm in the
background like we got a problem
I'm like what haven't seen these guys
panic at all me we got a problem
I know if you heard or not like oh [ __ ]
something's going down man yes someone
took a shirt
so what I hope I apologize on the behalf
of Calgarians and he's like getting
choked tibias someone took your shirt I
know what so also to get single so do
you see those triggers yeah I know I
don't give a [ __ ] man call I don't care
at all give them away it's all good man
yeah it's not good and goes I'm on it no
no and he leaves I don't know no it's
not
you leave business I'm doing great
Jay's there you know we're doing a thing
security and those three guys come
rushing in and I'm like what the fwhat
and I forgot we had that what happening
is he's there and they have a picture
they went through the video my the time
to hit that and have this for one
picture this guy looking and I'm talking
to the guy they tell you were yeah
and they take him down that's [ __ ]
hell I literally take him down him and
his buddy take him out the building I'm
like I guys I have the shirt it's not a
big deal - the shirt like not on our
watch not on our time like I love you
guys they were the best Avicii I'm not
really into EDM music huge yeah big
normos annyeong 28 years old
yeah well he passed away friend and
worked in Vegas in the night scene and
they were saying - saying that he he had
a residency at Wynn and actually fired
him from that because he was on stage
and fell asleep because you're on heroin
he's on here oh he has called bladder
and spleen removed so he between he's
partying hard to kill heroin and I knew
it was a problem yeah they knew it was a
problem then he was just spinning out of
control
okay but did you see in his hometown on
the belt you see them playing you
like the church playing his music in the
morning no oh my god do you guys not pay
it's all over oh dude you this no no
that's that's just the main hitter all
yeah that's no but it's good you type in
church bells for god sakes Church just
typing Avicii church bells double at
home town they're Dutch church bells
pain fitting tribute no get a stone that
a fan question on my show about I guess
it was better at Google chant or Stevie
Wonder I voted Stevie that's true yeah
some solid people who said lesbian cop
in the left that's weird
snake you know that the commies doors
always been fine yeah yeah he's really
super funny I remember one time he
called me up many guys not because you
want to see Brian Adams and Def Leppard
I go the answer will always be yes just
so you know that I go what's the deal
you guys it's in San Bernardino and I go
how are we getting there and he goes I
got a helicopter well I go yeah that's I
guess all right yes do it
yep so we go to Santa Monica Airport we
get a helicopter it's him me and him and
this hot blonde he's with smoking hot so
we get in the helicopter take off and
then I realized there's no bathroom in a
helicopter I'm really smart I barely
graduated junior high school so yeah
there's no bathroom helicopter have to
pee violently oh so I'm sitting there
and we have like another like 40 minutes
so I go I have to pee like really bad
like the dangerous a bad so did David
goes we'll just go out of the window so
there was this little slide window and I
slid it and I'm so dumb but I thought
you could just pee and it would just go
out no like it would just go like a
little stream huh and it just hit it
like a fan and just sprayed all over his
date all over the deck ya know all over
and they're both screaming and he's like
what the [ __ ] are you doing that's like
you said pee out of the window because I
was
okay you can't pee out of a [ __ ]
helicopter I go sorry magnum p.i and
I'll [ __ ] live this rogue lifestyle
you [ __ ] little L [ __ ] twink you
covered them in sports year and sports
in urine yeah oh and shower girl shower
you [ __ ] yeah bring me it brings you
down to earth because you guys are
you're high above you're above traffic
you think you're better than me watch
this enjoy wearing my piss yeah just
shoot me I will with my piss that's your
new show Oh God that made simple rules
of pissing on your day yeah yeah have
you ever had to call 9-1-1 have you ever
had somebody attack you cuz you have
fans stalkers I've had some weird stuff
but nothing like too bad
I've been anybody attacked me yeah yeah
I think cuz I surround myself with body
garage options I have giants a circle
like Floyd Mayweather
yeah I've Floyd Bennett me over me
whether you watch sports a lot right I'm
like I have a horrible sports problem
where it's like to the point where my
agent called me we were on this tour and
he's like there's some cities like we
probably can't go to you and I was like
why cuz I just would get drunk in his
tweet like belligerent horrible things
oh really oh my god yeah yeah it's like
I get yeah I my twitter during football
season is so out of control